عمليه التحول الديمقراطي والانتقال للحكم
المدني في السودان فشلت وانتهت بالفوضى
وبوادر حرب اهليه والسبب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقول صحيفه وولز جورنال الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان واشنطن اخطات في قراءه الوضع
السياسي في الخرطوم وحفزت المنافسه بين
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمدتي
على بناء قوتيهما وتحديدا بعد تبني سياسه
اصلاح قطاع الامن في السودان بما يضمن وضع
الرجلين تحت السيطره المدنيه وهذا الامر
لم تصدقه الا واشنطن تقول الصحيفه
الامريكيه منذ الاستقلال عام
1956 شهد السودان سبعه عشره انقلاب نجحت
منها سته وحربين اهليتين وصراع اباده
جماعيه في دارفور ورغم هذا لم تقرا واشنطن
جيدا المشهد السياسي في السودان مما ادى
الى اتجاه البلاد نحو الانهيار ومعها
العمليه الديمقراطيه التي دعمتها واشنطن
منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس السابق عمر البشير
عام 2019
ابعد من ذلك فشلوا الحسابات السياسيه
للاداره الامريكيه ادى الى جذب انتباه
روسيا والصين حيث تعتبر السودان ارض الذهب
والنفط والموارد المعدنيه الاخرى وربما
لاجل كل هذه التشابات حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان الصراع في السودان قد
يبتلع المنطقه كلها محاسن حداره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات